it's great to welcome to the program
today dr. Aaron Carroll who's a
professor of pediatrics at Indiana
University's School of Medicine and the
Regan Strief Institute I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly who writes
about health research and policy at the
New York Times and his blog the
incidental economists and has a youtube
show on these topics called healthcare
triage so great to have you on today
thanks for having me
so let's start our conversation about
evaluating different systems of
healthcare and paying for healthcare
maybe by establishing how we would
measure how well a system functions what
are the key things that we should be
thinking about
are they availability of care quality of
care and outcomes the cost per capita
like how do we even establish the
guidelines for figuring this out so we
care about all of those things so
whenever we talk about a healthcare
system or any kind of health care reform
I always like to frame it in terms of
what some people refer to as the Iron
Triangle but there are three aspects of
a healthcare system you always need to
think about how much does it cost
what's its access like how easy is it
how can you get the stuff that you want
or need and then what is the quality
that it produces what makes it an Iron
Triangle is that you can make any one
maybe two of those things better but it
often comes at the expense of the third
I can make a system that's cheaper
tomorrow but then probably it's either
gonna be less quality or there won't be
as much of it I can make a system
Universal tomorrow
meaning everybody can have everything
they want again that's gonna cost more
or probably quality or suffer and I can
give you the best system in the world
but then again that's gonna cost money
or you know access is gonna suffer in
some way so the problem is that we are
always looking for a silver bullet that
does all three of those things at the
same time it's just not gonna happen
so most healthcare reform that we want
to consider we have to say what are we
trying to achieve and what are we
willing to give up in order to get there
what are the trade-offs we don't engage
in that now within those three domains
there's lots of ways to measure a
healthcare system with respect to cost
is it public cost or private cost how
much is out-of-pocket how much of
premiums how much would you still have
to pay even after
how much should come out of taxes it
gets very complicated but the United
States is an incredibly expensive system
no matter how you're breaking yeah I
want to get to that in a second I mean
one of the things that I recently read
Yui Rhinehart's latest book where he
when he talked about the cost he says
something which makes sense but I think
is often not in the conversation that
happens at least in the media about
health health care which is that as you
point out there is some total cost and
that can go up or down what is the total
cost to treat the average person in a
year and then oftentimes what we're
really debating is actually how should
that total cost be divided from the
population in other words should we tax
richer people more in order to pay or or
so on and so forth is that a part of the
discussion that is maybe not spoken
about in those clear terms sometimes I
think it's part of but it's not even oh
you know part of it is that we think we
have a very private system and we do
compare it to some countries but still
about two-thirds of healthcare spending
in the United States is what we would
consider not private it's public meaning
that it's it's Medicare its Medicaid all
of which a tax payer or some other way
you know government-run it's the VA it's
everyone that works for a public
institution but has private insurance
like me I work for Indiana University
it's a statement you're all paying my
salary in taxes and you're all paying my
health insurance even though I have
private health insurance it's public
taxpayer money which is paying for it
I'm sure when you add all that up it's
like two thirds of healthcare spending
is already publicly financed in the
United States that's almost more per
person than any other country pays total
and then on top of that we still feel
like we're all privately paying way too
much money for premiums at our jobs and
even on top of that we feel like we're
paying way too much money out of pocket
when it comes to co-pays and deductibles
so no matter which way you want to
measure how we're spending on what the
cost of care is in the United States
it's it's just unbelievably high
especially I mean who may be the first
person to tell you you know rest is sold
but but it's the prices it's it's not
even just how much are we consuming but
it costs
more per unit in the United States than
anywhere else you could possibly imagine
and so our costs are just through the
roof and it's and of course everybody
wants that to be less or lower but you
can't do that without sacrificing access
or quality likely in some way so let's
get into it because it's so much of our
economy right it's drastically reduce
healthcare spending tomorrow we would
instantly be in recession and/or
depression yes so that's another really
interesting thing from reinhardt's book
where he says if you actually read you
know spending in health care is jobs
yeah in a very practical sense and I
have this idea that if we reduce
spending but get rid of extraneous
things like medical billing and
insurance fraud investigations that it's
all okay some people will have to find
new jobs but there is a very direct link
between total health care spending and
employment we're not when we say waste
it's not money that we put in a pile and
burn all of that waste is another
person's income it's it's you know it's
paying for stuff and people and jobs and
not even just you know drugs but the
people that work at the drug company the
people to clean the offices at the drug
company the people that pave the Lots
outside of the drug it's 16 17 18
percent of GDP in the United States
meaning about what 1/7 one-eighth of our
economy is healthcare if you say
tomorrow let's instead of spending 18
percent let's spend 16 percent we just
drop GDP by two percentage points we
render depression right so along those
lines my you know I I am I believe
Medicare for all would be a much better
system than the one we have at the same
time I have looked into enough of the
specific proposals that I see what may
be a problem with some of the plans for
how to pay for it and I want to see if
you agree with me or where maybe I'm
getting this wrong it seems to me that
most of these plans assume in order to
make the numbers work a drastic
reduction in healthcare spending per
capita in the United States that would
put us depending on the plan that you
look at in line with maybe Canada or
Australia and I have not seen a good
defense of how that's going to
happen aside from whether it would be
good or bad we can debate that part I
understand that if you eliminate some of
the quote waste from the multi insurance
billing system and different things
you'll reduce cost a little bit but I
don't see how it gets reduced so much is
that a fair critique of some of the
plans for how to pay for it or am i
maybe missing something of some of it
yes but I would say it's even it's even
a little more complicated than that
because again I would talk of it in
terms of trade-offs like we were at the
beginning sure so single-payer health
care which is what medicare for all it's
a perfectly viable way to improve access
that's what it would do it would get us
to universal so that point gets able
what's the trade-off are we gonna
sacrifice quality or are we gonna
sacrifice we're gonna spend more money
and we could absolutely spend more money
and then and everything would be fine
but if we're not then we have to say
well then what will the TriNet be if
we're going to significantly reduce
spending at the same time that we're
massively increasing access to imagine
the quality has to suffer in some way
but the broader picture is exactly what
you said like there's no magic to this
single-payer health care systems are not
inherently cheap they're cheap because
they can use their single-payer market
power to force every provider and
purveyor of health care to accept lower
reimbursement and so that's where the
magic comes in Medicare often reimburses
less than private insurance because they
just have all the patients and they can
turn to providers and say we've got all
these patients if you want to make a
living you have to accept the insurance
to where that is theoretically if
everyone was on Medicare then the
government would have enormous power to
say everyone's gonna have to accept less
reimbursement that's how it's all going
to function well there are trade-offs to
that be it their innovation be it
through what people are willing or able
to provide the idea that everyone is
going to continue to operate at peak
performance for less money is not
realistic and again we can say oh well
we'll just take it out of fraud and
waste that's still somebody's income
that's still somebody working there's no
magic solution so medicare for all is a
perfectly viable way to achieve
universal coverage and theoretically to
put use market power to reduce
overall healthcare spending but there's
got to be trade-offs so now a defender
of the Medicare for All system would
hear you talking about that and say well
there's a combination of things there
that would go into this on the one hand
there is a stimulative even though yes a
reduction in total cost is a reduction
in jobs the stimulative effect for all
of the end users who no longer are
spending as much money out of pocket if
you believe those estimates and also are
not at risk of a bankruptcy because of
unpredictable health care spending all
of that money is going to have a much
more stimulative effect being spent at
businesses for example that will
increase government revenues and
therefore it's all sort of going to work
out in the end and in a way that is
relatively neat and tidy so what do you
think about that but I think it's
because Americans have no appetite for
cost control no I think what would
happen is that we padlet if we passed a
medicare-for-all what would happen is
the system would just cost much much
much more money because we could
theoretically use this market power that
we have in Medicare right now to curtail
or hold down Medicare spending and we
don't the government just keeps spending
more and more on Medicare to where you
have politicians on Medicare is gonna go
bankrupt it's spending too much I know
it does anything and what when I read
the analyses it seems as though the
access piece may well be as it's
expected to be the quality of care peace
if managed correctly may well be it
seems that it's just going to cost more
than most as the plans are accounting
for and maybe not now maybe that's okay
as a decision that a country can make
and that's that's where it's like if
somebody said to me like well them
budgets like I I believe we have plenty
of appetite to spend a fortune on health
care given that there are better ways to
do this that would provide higher
quality and better access for the
enormous amount of money we seem willing
to spend
I think deep in people's hearts that's
where Medicare for all would wind up if
it was passed is that it would achieve
universal access in order to avoid real
problems in quality we would just keep
spending more and more and more money
because we have no appetite to say no it
would just not hit the budget
projections that people think
and then with them how would we pay for
that
I think likely if if someone actually
had the political power to get Medicare
for all through it would be on the backs
of things like wealth taxes and trying
to squeeze more money out of the the
people at the very high yeah I mean
that's part of it there's also this this
is a political reality where there's
never a question of how do we pay for
this war or there's weapons there but
it's a debate here and and I think that
that's a reasonable critique yeah and I
think that that's I think that's why if
Medicare for all was the past that's how
it would work it would be it would just
be very very expensive I don't think we
have much of an appetite for saying no
to individuals for healthcare stuff that
they have no matter if it works or not I
don't think we have much of an appetite
for for really impending people's
ability to get what they want in terms
of access as quickly as they want nor
are we gonna suffer much in terms of
quality decline so we'll just spend a
lot and we've been doing it for a long
time and that's what we would do and I
think the arguments would be if it were
to pass exactly what you said it we
don't seem to worry about how much the
war cost or or how much the tax cut
costs why are you all screaming about
how much the health care cost everyone's
getting it they're feeling better about
it let's just spend a ton of money now
if it were just up to you because you've
looked at so many systems you've looked
at European systems there's the system
in Singapore which we've talked about
before which is very interesting do you
find that there is some other system
that might be better suited for the
United States specifically so this is
what we about two and a half years ago
we did this thing at the New York Times
where we actually we picked eight
country's healthcare systems and we had
a tournament like to the bracket and let
both experts and the public vote and in
the end it came down to a battle between
France and Switzerland Switzerland won
and I think that's a reasonable call
Switzerland has a health care system
which is universal and it is entirely
private there is no Medicare or Medicaid
is kind of thing it's entirely private
well-regulated mostly nonprofit health
insurance not coupled to jobs from birth
to death from with a sliding scale
subsidy for those at the low end of the
socio-economic spectrum so subsidies to
help people buy it
they achieve remarkable outcomes they
have pretty high levels of cost-sharing
which we seem to believe in and their
costs are high compared to most of the
world but not to us
and and it's great and it's it's
entirely private there was a plan not
that long ago perhaps a little more than
a decade ago it's called widen Bennett
it was Ron Wyden who's a you know
Democrat from Oregon and it was a Bill
Bennett who was a Republican from Utah
so it was a totally bipartisan plan and
they had co-signers from both sides of
the aisle and it was this it was birth
to death exchange like insurance totally
private with subsidies or or tax credits
uncouple it from jobs very Switzerland
like there was a time in the United
States when now would have been be good
compromise solution but in the heat of
the ACA and all the political
ramifications and partisanship it got
crushed Bennett got run at office no one
will touch that but I personally think
that there's probably more of an
appetite for that kind of tightly
regulated private insurance that could
be marketed as a compromise ish type
solution for America that would still
allow for you know still not government
running it as much as say a
medicare-for-all would be and a
perfectly viable way to achieve
universal access um coverage that's up
actually both the both the French and
Swiss systems or ones ones that we've
talked about extensively interesting
interesting to hear that we've been
speaking with dr. Aaron Carroll who's a
professor of pediatrics at Indiana
University School of Medicine make sure
to check out his YouTube program on
these topics called healthcare triage
thank you so much for your time I really
appreciate it
anytime